once again it's Thursday this marks the
end of yet another week of shows in
quarantine it's getting a little fuzzy I
think we started doing this around 1986
that's just how it feels I think
Bananarama was on the charts I don't
know it's been a long time we're all
losing our minds I put a tie on today I
tied it just so I could remind myself
that I'm still alive but hanging in
there we're all doing the best we can
you know one thing that people been
saying is that this has been a chance
for people to see how celebrities live
that celebrities can open up and show
you how they really are at home and I
guess you could accuse me of not showing
you very much it's always the very same
picture right here it's got my my old
that's my first electric guitar there
that I bought years and years ago
that's a Gretsch Tennessean people say
hey man we want you to open up your
whole life to us man that's what hippies
are saying so here we go I'll show you
what else is here right next to it's a
green Gretch and next to that is an
orange Gretch yes I just completely
stripped myself naked in front of you I
showed you who I am